well i haven't spoken to marcus since
since june but i
as i say i think that uh what he's doing
is is terrific
and we support the local councils and
indeed
we we fund other local councils uh and
many of the organizations
that are helping in this period but
we're also
as i said uplifting universal credit uh
by a thousand pounds
and we think that is one of the best
ways uh you can help
families in this tough time i'm i
totally understand
the issue of of holiday hunger it is
that
we have to deal with it the issue the
the debate is
how do you deal with it and we're very
proud of the of the
support that we've given i've said
repeatedly throughout this crisis
that the government will support
families and businesses
jobs and livelihoods across the country
we're going to continue
to do that and just repeat my my single
point my most important point
we don't want to see children going
hungry
this winter this christmas certainly not
as a result of any
inattention by this government and
you're not going to see